[Music]
president biden finally addressing the
supply chain jam that threatens to roil
yes royal
the holiday season and also jesse
junior's christmas gifts oh i know it's
terrible it comes amid another slew of
bad headlines showing joe's
metamorphosis into jimmy carter is
almost complete
americans are quitting their jobs at a
record pace 4.3 million left their posts
in august inflation surging more than
expected in september with consumers
paying 5.4 percent more for goods
compared to last year
and the white house is warning shoppers
their stockings are going to look empty
not mine
outright saying there will be things
that people can't get
here's the president
the port of los angeles announced today
that it's going to be begin operating 24
hours a day seven days a week today's
announcement has the potential to be a
game changer fedex and ups two of our
nation's biggest freight movers are
committing today to significantly
increase the amount of goods they're
moving at night but now we need the rest
of the private sector chain to step up
as well
this is not called a supply chain for
nothing one of the reasons why i think
it's very important that we get the the
infrastructure plan passed we've seen
the cost of inaction in the pandemic
in the delays and the congestion that
affect every american yeah it's up to
you now to step up
the federal government that's in charge
of the postal service saying earlier
that they aren't actually the postal
service
can
this administration guarantee
that holiday packages will arrive on
time
we are not the postal service or ups or
fedex we cannot guarantee what we can do
is use every lever at the federal
government disposal to reduce delays to
ensure that we are
addressing bottlenecks in the system
no wonder the president's popularity is
sinking faster than hunter's nose and
amount of fine bolivian flake
it's a cocaine joke no it's a chocolate
bar it's a british cadbury flake
chocolate bar
so so dana when you hear about what it
always comes down to now it's up to us
it's not it's the government
it's not really our fault to build the
president's speech today is the
president is going to take action and
then the action is that you are the
problem do you honestly think that there
are any retailers or business people in
america who don't want to sell stuff
yeah of course they do and people and do
you think the truck drivers don't want
to get paid do you think the people the
problems have been building for a long
time it takes about six months for one
of these things to deal with it so
jesse jr might get his gifts on easter
yes at this rate and you know he won't
care
he'll be grateful
i also believe that we could actually we
could have a segment on the five reading
through with a dramatic interpretation
the chief of staff's retweets and tweets
about how great it is that
unemployment's at five percent and this
is great because now people are going to
get paid more to do things okay however
employers spent the last six months
competing with the federal government
for the fact of enhanced unemployment um
the the benefits for the workers they
they reduce their businesses they cut
their hours they serve fewer customers
you think that they don't want to of
course they do and maybe there are
structural things that have happened in
the economy but what also has happened
is the inflation so cnbc called it today
a two percent uh pay cut
for people in america so you can pay
more but that means that people are also
paying more at the grocery store at the
pump um it will be a dark holiday season
i saw one funny cartoon with uh santa
telling a little kid sorry we're also
out of coal
but that's a you just bring up a great
point when you judge coal that creates
energy the dems are saying they're
promising everything is going to get to
every how does everything how do they
how does this stuff get moved
it's it's fuel it's fuel which is like
exactly it's like but this so what we're
seeing maybe is a premonition or a
foreshadowing of what happens in the
clinton green
new deal this is what we should be
getting used to right right get used to
the fact that you're not going to be
able to get anything you used to get
because we're now part of this new
climate change new green deal you're not
going to have anything but what i love
about this story the most is the ability
of the white house to deflect you know
while inflation is rising wage earners
aren't making more money more people are
quitting because they can make more
money staying at home this is all the
white house's problem and donald trump
predicted this last year he said this
was going to happen and by the way who's
a genius who just figured out you know
we can get more done if we work seven
days a week 24 7. are you stupid i mean
really so this is this is what i think
the problem is i think people don't want
to work they're not getting paid to work
they think that there's a a benefit at
the end if they don't work and the
people who want to work can't get the
jobs that they want to get you know uh
geraldo i went and called bmw
seems that uh your mini will not be
arriving for at least another seven
months i'm glad you brought it up
because uh my
uh my 16 year old is driving and i'm
very nervous about that but she's
excellent here's my point and i think
this helps solve this whole dilemma
unions have to listen to what i'm about
to say come on board
why do you have to be 21 years of age to
drive these big rigs
why not 18 why not the hardest thing to
do is employ
inner city kids from 18 to 21. they
graduate high school then you got to
keep them
legal until they can become a member of
the police force or something like that
it's very very difficult 18 to 21 let
them be our drivers they can pass these
tests it enormously increases the pool
of available drivers and that i submit
it's not the ships it's the trucks
that's why those containers are sitting
on those docks right and there's no one
to drive them let the kids do it hey
that was on america's newsroom this
morning it was a high school student and
a professor yeah he's 18 years old he's
like i think i could have a career great
great but aren't they even talking about
relaxing the requirements to be a
commercial truck driver i mean well
that's one you could really get to that
and there's one more thing more
controversial
it's hard to reach the pedals yes
the
mexicans are great drivers you i just
came back from mexico they're everywhere
give temporary visas
until my 18 to 21 plan comes into effect
give the mexican drivers temporary
temporary underlying temporary visas and
let them drive domestically in the
united states
you did not say mexicans are great
drivers uh i mean they're bringing in
our
a good place it's not kids the truck
driver swirl though look around the
table where is this made where's this
mid china everything around here is made
in china now whose fault is that joe
biden and his buddies made sure that
after the cold war they brought all the
factories from here all the way to china
and east asia so now the american
destiny is tied to china's destiny
that's how we have a pandemic that's how
we have supply chain problems that's why
jesse jr is not going to get anything
for christmas i'm sorry jesse jr it's
china's fault
and joe biden's fault have you talked to
him about this no but i i hope he's not
watching
for many many reasons and joe biden had
a great opportunity to do this after the
lab leak he could have been inaugurated
and saved guys we're going to make you
pay the price we're going to incentivize
all these companies to remove these
factories bring them here bring them to
the western hemisphere even if they're
in our hemisphere the shipping lanes are
much quicker and much easier and just go
south to north but no no no imagine what
the supply chain problem is going to
look like if taiwan blows up or the
chinese real estate bubble blows up or
the next variant sweeps through that
country it's going to be a mess you're
going to order stuff off amazon it's
never going to get here you're going to
have to build your own furniture do you
want to sit in furniture i built
absolutely not i don't even want to do
that so he goes out there today and says
you know what i'm going to call some
companies so they can hire more drivers
and then in the same sense he says we
need to go green more truckers make this
a green economy doesn't make any sense i
can imagine donald trump if this had
happened under his watch he would have
had in the oval he would have had the
head of the trucking union guy he would
have had the shipping magnates there and
he would have had a whole conversation
gotten some consensus there and said
this is what we're going to do let's see
it happen it would have been a great can
you
just uh state your name introduce
yourself okay you remember what we used
to do
right and now joe said he called someone
steve apple um
i just want to mention one other thing
the president has not had a cabinet
meeting since july 20th
what a shock no time like the president
such a boring group there you go hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else